he's the Texans defensive end JJ Watt
joining us good to see him again he
joins us on behalf of Papa John's the
official pizza sponsor of the NFL and
Super Bowl 51 cleared to play ready to
go but you couldn't play today if you
were the Super Bowl could you well I was
on IR so I can't come on good but let's
say you hypothetically Super Bowl Texans
were in it I mean I imagine I would it's
the biggest game in the world I'd find a
way yeah do you do you think you'll
change your style of play with all the
surgeries you Penn I think it's going to
be I think it's more of changing the
style of training I think it's a lot
more football the game on the field you
can't control what happens you know
you're you're playing you're flying
around you're going to get hit different
ways you don't know how to how that's
going to go but what I can control is my
training so you control what you do you
control the situations you put yourself
in and training and you make sure that
you're smart in that aspect and then you
minimize the risk and obviously on the
field what happens happens but as long
as you build yourself up to be as strong
as possible then they're going to
minimize the risk have you over trained
oh no no I'm not in previous years you
have none no I mean I'm I'm sure that
I've done training that there's a point
of minimal return you know I mean I'm
sure of them workouts that didn't get me
anything because I was doing so many in
a week but now they're definitely not
over saying what do you care about this
week little bit with the Super Bowls or
anything you're curious about and you
know what sit here in your in your town
yeah I think that's the biggest thing
for me is it being here in Houston and
being able to see the city kind of show
off its culture show off you know the
great restaurants we have the people
that we have here it's interesting to
see how it all works you know having it
be in your own City and for me being
able to sleep in my own bed as opposed
to having to go somewhere else um but I
will say you know going into the stadium
to work out every day and seeing
somebody else's face on your stadium is
not fun
that's definitely motivation it's a
weird year for you very weird year yeah
yeah how did you get down on yourself
depressed
I wish I could have like this like super
positive answer like no I was
unbelievable the whole time I was super
strong ahead but there were there
definitely some down times there
sometimes it you really start to just
look at things in general and you go
through three surgeries in one year it's
tough but you start to realize what's
really important you know who's really
important what really truly matters to
you and one of the thing that you love
is taken away from you and the thing
that you worked so hard your whole life
for is taken away from you you really
realize how special and how important it
is and obviously grateful to have an
opportunity to play again and I think
there's just a rejuvenated energy
because of that but you see this story
with Pat McAfee at age 29 announcing
he's retiring and he's a punter right
now you've had all these surgeries right
you've been decorated could you see a
point where you just surprise people in
you walk away not I'm going to hang on
all right gonna go I wake up one day and
that's it I'm going to tell people I've
done I've done enough in the next four
years let's say I could definitely see
how that how that point could come about
there's no doubt I'm not saying that
that's that's going to come for me but I
could see how it could come about for
certain guys and I think that honestly
that's one area where the injuries this
last season having to miss most of the
season kind of makes you recalibrate
things because when things are things go
well for so long and you stay healthy
for so long and you're very fortunate to
play well it kind of gets into like this
almost not monotonous but it's just like
okay this is how it's going to go this
is how it's going to go and when
something shakes it up like the injury
and you miss the whole year it really
makes you realize how special it was and
and not that you didn't know was special
before but when it's taken away from you
you really truly realize how fortunate
you are to wake up and play football for
a living I mean we play a game for a
living it's the coolest thing in the
world so I don't know if there will be a
surprise any day but you know what you
want to do enter football I mean it's
going to go one of two ways in my
opinion I I think at the end of the day
someday I'm definitely end up coaching
high school football just just being a
regular husband and a dad somewhere
coaching high school football because I
my high school coach had a big impact on
me and I feel like that's an area where
you can really help mold young minds
and put kids in a good position for
success but I think there's also the
possibility of doing things like movies
sometime down the road I think that's a
possibility as well but we'll see if
this kind of depends on where your life
takes me but you look at Michael Strahan
or do you look at the rock as somebody
inspiration where you can go on go you
know two different ways you write well I
think they both do incredible at what
they're doing I think Michael Strahan
does an unbelievable job with all I mean
the thing I would say about both those
guys is they work insanely hard you know
Michael Strahan is going from one shore
the next one actually flying across
country the rock is doing movie the
movie he's doing all these different
things so I would say that it all comes
down to what you want to do I would say
I would go I would lean more towards the
movie side than you want to be a
superhero
oh sure why not no no I mean yeah why
not right yeah yeah as long as you're
the good guy yeah you'd be the good guy
right now you don't have to be right
yeah you can be the bad guy you'd like
to be the bad guy I don't say I'd like
to be but I wouldn't have a problem with
it can you play the role of the bad
absolutely really yeah absolutely
why not you strike me as a polite bad
guy though probably you know yeah I mean
you saw the speech last oh yeah yeah
yeah like before I kick your ass let me
comb my hair let me brush my teeth I
gotta tell my mom I love her apologize
you are
he took my service kryptonite's out
there I'm sorry excuse me I'm going to
have to kill ya young would you like
something to wash it down with
yeah JJ want joining us how many
questions are you getting this week
about Broncos water first one we got one
really right is it because you haven't
been available to have anybody ask you
know I've been available I had a four
media session yesterday nobody asked
about the quarterbacking situation there
no why I don't is there a question do
you think there's a question at the
quarterbacking position what's the
question is Brock Osweiler the future of
this team I don't know I don't I don't
know I don't know the answer but as a
teammate and I know it's an awkward
situation here but you know you're
looking at this you got your own or even
talking about maybe we'll look in the
draft for a quarterback what do you say
what he's the one inside the checks I
mean yeah but you know it's got to be
frustrating for a great defense the
offense
is not holding up its end of the bargain
I mean all we can do as a defense go out
there and stop them from putting points
in the end zone I mean as a defensive
player
it's obviously not terribly realistic
but your mindset has to be if you give
us three points we're going to win the
game you know so we have to have that
mentality I think with the way our
defense played this year they were they
were phenomenal there was a lot of fun
to watch them play and fly around and
for me to be able to watch that and know
that there's certain points where I can
come out there and even enhance that and
make it even more more fun to plan that
defense it's going to be I can't wait to
get back out there with the guys it is
such a good job
yeah but the problem is the the offense
did give you only three points except
China this year exactly that's the part
of the working on that we're working on
you're going to go back to playing
offense I know I did the quarterback
didn't go out - okay are you retiring
from offense would you like to know
every day I remember that I mean I don't
know it's not my decision as the head
coach's decision but I enjoy it I think
the I think the tight end obviously
worked out better than the the Wildcat
quarterback for me and that one goes
there but I have fun with it and I think
it's actually valuable I mean get a guy
with that size and yeah I mean obviously
Gronk has been extremely successful and
I would say I'm nowhere near that but I
mean being able to toss the ball up to
somebody with with big size in the end
zone is a helpful thing how is the
offseason Polly had sad face when he
showed me a picture with you with the
girls
it was a girl my friend or is it
girlfriend
JD I was just showing a picture of the
beach and the sunset I don't know what
was in that I know she's great she's
great yeah it's official like yeah we've
been together for a while now yeah
was her birthday on Tuesday so just
wanted to wish her a happy birthday and
kind of I mean it's in today's day and
age it's kind of one of those like I
guess formalities that she just put it
out there but she's awesome
I mean she's a sense of you know I guess
so much pride when I watched her play
and you get motivated and it's a lot of
fun to watch her play with the national
team to watch it play with the - who's a
better athlete
that's the household debate there we
just won on that trip this weekend we
did these look like oh she's she's very
similar to me in that way that we
compete all the time so whether it's you
know little things like ping pong or
finding a way to create a little
soccer game in the room we're always
competing so it's uh she's much better
than it made and endurance and so she
can run for days we have yet to race she
claims she's faster than me who which
I'm not 100% sure on that and I also
I've made some very big claims about my
abilities to stop a penalty kick which I
think I spoke out of turn on those so
we're going to find that out here in
probably a couple months so you get it
film that no absolutely not
although they'd be great I just want one
out of ten because I mean that's a
fairly good what do you think what do
you think a good ratio is for probably
you always [ __ ] if you stopped a two
out of ten that's good
well I don't know if I can do two boys
the over-under is one and a half we're
setting it I feel like I could do that I
feel I could do what do you run the 40
in uh I think at the comment I was like
a four seven eight
we don't you know really time before tea
after that day yes your life yeah but
are you running for da huh let's see at
the combine or today Oh today uh I like
to be in around the tens you know like
that's my time like why get there then
it's over
absolutely I like to take a good time
yeah yeah absolute like a photo op
that's like I'm running in slow motion
and I am yeah great form though yeah
absolutely yes it's like that movie
Chariots of Fire when they're running on
the factory
I mean I'm running a real music running
in real speed uh your uh your brother is
getting some the JJ Watt cliches here
leading up to the draft TJ hi my motors
that I motor you know student of the
game first in last out you know Molly do
you have the comparisons with the JJ and
brother TJ actually no they didn't
compare him to you first comparison I
thought Ryan Kerrigan oh yeah yeah yeah
white guy I motor
so I'm believable I mean well first
player good athlete is not a good
athlete I don't know it is limited
athletically is that something huh no
just statutes not about him is the kid
he is he is very athletic he he is fun
to watch but he does all those things do
are true he is an unbelievably high
motor he is very
led to me but he's a lot of fun to watch
the thing I like watching about him last
year was just the energy that he plays
with he's so much fun I mean who is
better and he had a same eight-six Jamie
oh he's much better than me at that at
that edge really yeah much better he's
much more refined he's much he's got
better instincts than I had at that age
he had more sex I mean I think my last
year Wisconsin had seven and a half and
this year he had eleven and a half I
mean he's he's a very very good player
he's he's smart he's only been at the
position for two years a year and a half
now but he's he's very very good but it
feels ejections had the opportunity to
draft him oh absolutely yeah I love it
it would be the best rookie hazing of
all time no we don't haze anymore yeah
no yeah right surely the best rookie
poking fun of all time what they do to
you what was your hazing I was very
proactive so first they come in I said
what do you guys want just to get them
any snacks they want any food they want
anything they want you get you try and
pay for the dinner right out of the gate
you try and try and went very very
proactive and it was it was very
effective I'm trying to think
it really wasn't Kari shoulder pads
carry helmet stuff like that
biggest dinner tab you had to pick up
the rookie year wasn't too bad my rookie
dinner tab was was like I think is four
or five grand which is I mean obviously
a lot of money but compared to some of
the rookies head to see it wasn't I saw
like the $55,000 ones coming out and I
was trying to how I started check out if
I needed to take a mortgage up you know
yes you're making the tour here with
pompe Jones yeah it's a it's Papa John's
obviously pizzas been a background in my
in my life for a long time and family so
Papa John's is all about the pizza
family and it's all about the people
behind the pizza making a pizza so
they're supporting Papa John's Pizza
family calm right now
the official provider Super Bowl Sunday
and obviously Sunday being the biggest
piece of day of the year it's a great
time to get some Papa John's you know
it's good to see you man great this
crazy lady got cleared you have
appreciate healthy enough and I never I
never got to see any every time I come
on the show there's some sort of antics
like one year I got to
the basketball one year I got to hit him
with a pie when you're going on lack of
poly I'd like somebody to tackle poly
today I can't do it I'd like somebody to
hmm I just want to see somebody get hurt
that's kind of how I want to see my
efforts Michael Bendis would be a great
person to do that metallic would pull we
down hello
I bet he would love that Michael Bennett
yeah he's a bad dude he would love that
yeah he thinks he might do it just to do
it
he might do it before somebody asked him
I was wondering doesn't seem like a
friend he doesn't seem he seemed like
he'd really do it oh yeah no you did you
you may be getting two surgeries and by
the way pretty was telling you about his
surgeries yes now you said he had double
hernia sir he had two surgeries
yeah and your response having had
surgeries it fritz he had two surgeries
officially if he's talking to the
cheerleaders he had two yes Jesus
talking to us he had one because your
monitor if you go under anesthesia once
and they do two things during that
session that's one surgery most
surgeries you had in one day was what
procedures most procedures I had in one
day
my groin I had five things five five eat
that 45 too long now was that one
surgery it was one surgery by per day
one surgery five see so there's there's
six incisions yeah so - - and my left a
doctor's one on each side of my core and
then there's two for a little two-bit
winner holy son yeah it was uh he and I
got I'll show you guys what else makes
now that that another jayjay that the
game operation Paulie plays with you
yeah you're that other guy where it
shows all the surgeries in like Oh JJ
had this picture and he actually has the
stuff they took out all right yeah I'm
not put on eBay
yeah anything that the website you need
to plan Papa John's Pizza family calm
and disorder Papa John's on Sunday he'll
make for a great game you're not getting
engaged anytime soon right my little
brother just got engaged my middle
brother Derek it is going Jay's so
selectively what you did right there
yeah well done thank you you just
deflected there that's class that's
great a deflecting that what that was
but then I come right back as you would
Brady throws the touchdown but then you
come right back mean we're right up to
Brady okay we just got an Instagram
photo
okay was white speeders anyway I've been
going out with her are we going out for
probably eight or nine months we don't
offer laugh good so what's it what's the
proper time food how long were you how
long would you say you have to date
before you married I knew I was going to
marry her when I met her okay so it took
a little while before I got around eight
months eight months is here it is like
am I good come on out
what's your addition oh I guess you're
not doing the bachelor no no I gotta do
that exactly why would I do that the
great show sure yeah sure it is I mean
yeah great it's a real love hoppin John
haha the official peach the sponsor of
the NFL in Super Bowl 50 one is JJ Watt
always great to see you ma'am I'm very
really thank you my buddy
[Applause]
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]